what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into Punisher war
machine n and god this is such a cool
story like this is like the cool thing
about The Punisher is you never really
know what direction his stories are
gonna go in one of these of funny things
- the way I want you to check it's not
it's actually like the Punisher is drawn
looked like Jon Bernthal which I'll have
a problem with - Jon Bernthal is like
the best version of The Punisher ever
but still like this picks up with like
traditional Punisher fare right like for
those of you guys who were who've never
ly read Punisher comics before but you
know about Frank castles character by
and large he just shows up and kills bad
guys and that's really it like there
really isn't a whole lot of development
to it outside of Punisher max by Garth
Ennis anyway that was one of the coolest
runs of his character but here it's just
like a couple of guys from like chair
edge here and I think it is from some
basically a defunct state that's
essentially undergone like a coup d'etat
who are basically like trading weapons
like they're literally honey for one of
their guys who had just kind of gone
missing uh and then they're like here in
the weapons cache when they open up the
weapons the guys head and is inside the
case with a grenade attached to it it
blows up and then it's just absolute
mass chaos and it's just like like
Punisher going through and just spraying
down everyone he sees and that's one of
the cool things about the Punisher the
Punisher takes no prisoners this guy
when he shows up where the bad guys are
everyone's gonna die but still like when
a couple of these guys basically jump
aboard you know what's more or less a
pontoon boat and then try to make their
escape we end up finding out the Frank
Castle head essentially just like lace
the boat and everything with like
explosives and like blows up the actual
the actual tanker itself and kills those
guys along with it and just like like
sinks the whole thing and so when he
finally gets back to his van and he gets
back to doing whatever he's gonna do
he's met by the arrival of Nick Fury now
Nick Fury actually takes him to a
location kind of a hideout more or less
but you end up having a Nick Fury
meeting with with Frank and essentially
saying like I've got a mission for you
now by and large Frank Castle avoids the
feds like he's like I don't have
anything to do with shield or what's
what's basically a defunct shield
because remember shields basically been
out the window ever since the events of
secret Empire so it's not really there
anymore
oh really I don't wanna have anything to
do with like the federal government I
don't work for you guys I did my time as
a Marine I'm on my own crusade now Nick
Fury is like yeah man but it involves
kids and that's the line when it comes
to Frank house when it comes to it to
the Punisher the line that he won't
cross his kids if anything ever happens
when it when it deals the kids all he'll
lose his mind that's why like if you go
and you what is it if you're going to
read the slavers to
from punisher max one of the darkest and
like most blood like just a blood
drenched arc by garth in its like it
deals with that like the slave trade and
and like he he goes ham it's amazing
like during that whole thing but
basically what we end up finding out
here is there's a guy named petrov who
led like a coup d'etat in this defunct
state in a part of a part of russia and
the result is that he's settling as many
scores as he can so it's like the
godfather and the head and the ends of
the five families the differences
actually it's really not the godfather
in the five families it's more like
kaiser so say and like all those guys
that took out his family assuming that
the the story that kevin spacey gave us
was to be believed if you never saw the
usual suspects you are missing out oh
god I love usual suspects you guys need
to go see usual suspect you guys need to
rent that or whatever but it's it's
amazeballs
anyway we end up also finding out that
after shield had essentially gone under
that some of the shield agents who were
stationed there by Nick theory had
basically turned coded against shield or
against United States and like ally
themselves with Petrov and so the result
is that Nick Fury's like you're the man
that I need here you are a former
blackops you know agent you were part of
the u.s. Marines you're trained in like
every form of hand-to-hand combat within
reason I mean he's not like War II or
anything you've got all these different
things that I need to basically send you
in is a one-man army and take these guys
out the problem is they're basically
using stark tech and is one of these
things were like this was technology
that was originally developed presumably
by Tony Stark and then basically given
to shields so that they can have their
own their own agents use their own their
own suits but the result is that these
guys took their suits with them when
they join Petroff and so in order to be
able to fight fire with fire
Frank Castle needs a suit of his own and
so what he ends up doing is actually
infiltrating a heavily armed and a
heavily guarded US Air Force Base and
that's what he finds the war machine on
more Machine suit that he was told about
by Nick Fury and of course the idea is
use this suit take out Petrov either
force my guys to come back or bring my
guys back whatever the case is and then
like hand the suit back over of course
its Frank hassle which means that's not
gonna happen and so following this what
ends up doing is actually showing up in
in this country itself and just kind of
like witnessing this old man who's being
taken away because it refuses to give
like crops and and needs and so on and
so forth to the guys who were there and
then Frank Castle just kind of takes him
out but notice how ruthless he is right
it's one of these interesting situations
because when when you think of Frank
Castle by and large it's just him with
some guns and so he really kind of has
to rely on like so
Rison brute-force right like take them
out before they even know what's going
on there's no shadow games or anything
like that it's just attack but when he's
war machine when he's got all this armor
on him he's learning about the armor as
he uses it not to mention he looks
absolutely beast with the Punisher and
sitting on it but basically is it's one
of these thing this is one of the
important things about Punisher Frank
castles not just like a rock killing
machine right I mean he is in the sense
of like he takes no prisoners and and he
asked no questions when it comes to
taking out bad guys but he's also a guy
with a heart so innocent people are
usually always allowed to go free it's
like get out of here before the killing
started it's one of these things he'll
walk into a buildings like anybody who
don't want to get murdered get out like
it's it's it's one of those things that
kind of unfolds that way but in this
instance its collateral damage because
this old man basically says hey look man
like these guys these guys you took out
it's cool you did but like their friends
are gonna come calling and when they do
they're gonna want to know what happened
to their friends and so ultimately
they're gonna take me out and they're
gonna start killing people until they
start getting answers and so Frank house
was like okay well if they want to come
here and if they want to if they want to
dance with the devil and the devil can
dance with them and so it's it's it's
literally like they bury the bodies he
sets up a roadblock that keeps like
they're armed transports from getting
any further and so they have to proceed
on foot and when they do
Frank hassle eradicate them all now
that's the experience of military
experience and like the veteran
experience of Frank hassel Frank hassle
is nothing if not methodical and
tactical and that's what makes him one
of the most dangerous people in the
Marvel Universe of course a couple of
these guys uh who are watching this
whole this this absolute massacre unfold
we're kind of like alright let's get out
of here let's go take refuge in the
house we'll be safe in there only to
only to realize the old man's in there
with a scythe and he just you start
knocking these guys to pieces now of
course the byproduct of this is that the
old man dies I mean you've got these
guys with weapons you know they've got
firearms so on and so forth and so the
old man dies but he basically tells
Frank look what you're doing here is the
right thing to do you got to take these
guys out you got to fix this stuff and
so what is it happening here is Punisher
kind of sits down and says okay look
this guy Petrov is exceedingly well
hidden this guy does not want to be
caught and so if he doesn't want to be
caught they'd all make him come out I
will stack the bodies so high then he'll
have no choice but to come out here but
this is a dangerous game that Frank
castles playing if he goes through and
he starts killing every single member of
Petrov's army that he can find then sure
like the mission will be carried out but
could be that Petrov will be more
dangerous when he's cornered than when
he's not cornered and so this kind of
comes as a bit of like a free looter
sorts in the sense that were Frank
hassles liberating all these different
people from all the different prisons he
suddenly met by the arrival of one of
the one of the shield agents using their
suit now the suit this agent uses is
well beyond Frank hassles but he doesn't
have experience he's flying around he's
taken him out and firing his weapons but
at the end of the day he doesn't really
know how to use every single facet of
his abilities and that's what Frank
Hausa literally just like gouges his
eyes out because he's like me you have
all these abilities all that kind of
stuff but you don't really know how to
use them effectively and so because of
the fact that like Cates was the dude
who was basically taken out we end up
finding out he was like the runt right
like he was like the small guy and the
whole thing and this proves itself in
the sense that were Frank hash was able
to take like one or two of them out all
the others are able to band together
pretty effectively and essentially like
bombard him with missiles and sent him
crashing down into the water and it was
kind of an interesting thing here
because while all this is happening like
Frank castles talking to the suit and
the suit is talking to him now where the
suit just like tells him obvious things
or like it responds to his sarcasm by
being sarcastic itself it's these are
these are cool little moments that
really could be built on and becomes
something awesome and so of course this
results in a couple of people fishing
Frank Castle out of the water and then
Frank Castle be who he is makes his way
to these guys who had taken him out
making their way back to to their base
of operations and then Frank hassel
ambushes them and essentially takes one
of them away now again this is stealth
guile you know grabbing a knife and just
sticking it to this guy's throat and
basically saying hey look I know you're
I know you're going P if you want me to
stab you and the one that winks and not
the one that stinks then you'll do what
I tell you to so like it's it's it's
it's pretty interesting like it's it's
pretty rough but then like he basically
goes through and this guy's like hey
look man like I can fix your suit but
like we'll have to go to one of these
bases which is like heavily armed and
guarded by like all of the oh all use of
in gosh and Petroff Frank Castle makes
quick work out him it happened so fast
we don't really even see a brunt of it
he's just going through and just like
taking all these individual guys out now
the problem with this is that in the
middle of this whole thing Nick Fury
basically pops up and he's like Frank
Castle what the heck are you doing and
reveals that this guy that Frank Castle
has who's gonna fix this suit can do
anything that he's just like a new guy
you know so of course Frank Castle kills
him because why not and of course this
sets about another ninja near inside the
facility fixing a suit instead but like
at this point it's literally him
continuing to go on this warpath he he
tells
like I want to know everything about
Petrov I want to know everyone he's ever
known I want to know who's lieutenants I
want to know his his right-hand men I
want to know all this stuff because I am
going to go through and I'm gonna kill
all these lieutenants all these guys and
anyone they ever met like I'm gonna wipe
out every single member of Petrov's
forces they're all gonna die that this
guy is not gonna have any choice but to
show up to actually take action and so
this is when Nick Fury basically chimes
in after all this is done this is when
he chimes in it says look man Petrov's
got nukes
so you need to leave he had to get out
of there because what you risk doing
right now is that while this guy's
basically partly he's the leader of a
sovereign country recognized by the
United States in the United Nations
you're committing an act of war if
people find out that you're acting on
behalf of a shield and by proxy the
federal government and then this is
basically gonna mean the United States
sanctioned an effort to take out an
existing and recognized world leader for
its own purposes it's an act of war and
of course that would lead to a massive
international incident especially if
this guy has nukes Frank hassles like
don't give a damn so like Frank Castle
Frank Castle takes off and it's like
like he literally shows up to this huge
meeting that that the petrov has where
he's talking to his guys and starts like
killing them all right in front of
petrov and the whole time he's like
taunting and they you know Petrov runs
into his bunker he's kind of hiding out
but the whole time he's taunting and
he's like look man like you can come out
here in face be or like I can come in
there and wipe you out either way you're
gonna die and so again it's kind of a
funny thing because again what makes
Frank castles so cool it's like his
small little tidbits of ingenuity as an
example so these guys show back up again
with their suits and of course Frank
Castle was outclassed and so it's not
just about like brute force it's not
just about using a suit and just like
running at them again and again and
again and again it's using small little
tactics here and there as an example one
of the things that he does is he grabs a
plastic explosive and sticks it to the
front of this guy's face and then slams
his mask down and blows his head up it's
just small stuff like that you know and
like at that point it's like he
literally jumps in one of the tanks one
of the other guys goes to respond and
gets yanked into the tank and he gets he
gets killed the other three guys start
blasting the tank they basically destroy
it only to flip it over and realize
Frank counsel burrow down under the
ground and then he like literally starts
grabbing them pulling them down and just
like tearing into pieces hitting them
with a piece of a tank now the whole
time Frank castles suit is like beyond
repair it's breaking down but like he's
like I don't care like these guys are
supposed to die and I'm gonna take them
out and it's cool because that's a
direct reflection of how Frank
hasil normally yes if he believes he can
win he'll keep going until he does
because his willpower is just that
insane and so in response to the fact
that essentially like all but two of his
soldiers have been taken out petrov ends
up like launching the nuke and it's a
coolest thing because frank castle
basically takes off ends up like like
tracking down the nuke and when he gets
to it he starts tearing through it piece
by piece and then comes back with the
warhead and so it's literally him just
there with a warhead and he's just like
okay so you guys like take off your
suits or i'm gonna blow this warhead up
do what i tell you to or like I'm gonna
use repulsor and detonate this new and
so because of the fact that he would
because of the fact that like like Nick
Fury knows he would and like everyone
watching knows a Frank Castle so crazy
that he would do it Nick Fury hits a
panic button and deactivates his suit by
activating an EMP of course it also
deactivates the suits of the people
around him this is kind of funny because
the guys are just like like oh man dude
his suit doesn't work you know and
Frank's responses and do you think that
makes me less dangerous or more
dangerous and like it makes them more
dangerous because now they're all on an
even footing and these guys are just
like yeah well we're trained by shield
and Frank castles like yeah but here's a
problem man shield is garbage I crushed
shield ages on the regular let me show
you how and like just it starts ripping
these guys to pieces and it's the
coolest thing it's one of the absolute
coolest things to see and so of course
what ends up happening here is when
Frank Castle and essentially eradicate
severy buddy all this left is Petrov and
under normal circumstances we would
expect Frank Castle to basically not
stand a chance the Frank Castle would be
taken out but again ingenuity quick
thinking Frank Castle basically jumps on
to the to the suit uses a dagger and
like punctures out one of the guy like
like punches out one of his eyes and so
it's like damn and then from there like
just starts hacking away at pieces of a
suit and the reason why is because
Petrov made the statement I'm using the
exact same suit you were which accused
Frank Castle off to the idea that he has
all the same weaknesses as the suit that
Frank counsel used now this is really
where the numbers kind of get fudged a
bit you know where Rosenberg Matthew
Rosenberg the writer kind of kind of
cooked the books a bit because at Frank
Castle had used the suit for like a day
he really wouldn't know all the
strengths and weaknesses but he would
know enough strengths and weaknesses to
be able to incapacitate somebody else
using the suit so what also kind of
works so of course when you have Petrov
who basically tries to take off Frank
Castle jumps on board and literally just
starts like taking out things like the
arc reactor deactivating the suit and so
the whole thing just comes crashing back
down to earth and it's one of the it's
one of the funny moments is kind of like
a way to end the story kind of a caveat
but what Frank hassel does is he
actually Hotwire's the repulsor hand of
of the suit that Petrov was using and
uses the repulsor blasts to push himself
back up now in reality it probably would
have sinem flying like I would just just
set him flying out in some direction
somewhere and who knows whether he would
have lived or died but it's the Punisher
it's Frank Castle he's like Batman he
always lives because you know he's
Batman you know free Castle basically
survives the whole ordeal the problem
with this is that he's off the
reservation now and like he can't be
found unless he wants to be found
even if he's wearing a great big huge
like Warmachine suit and so where Carol
Danvers shows up and she's like okay
what is going on here like like what
have you done what have you screwed up
Nick Fury's like Punishers got the war
machine suit and I have no clue where he
is and I have no clue what he's doing
and what we end up finding out here is
Punisher is doing what Punisher does he
has a war machine suit he already
toppled a dictator so now it's time to
go back to his roots Punisher travels
back to the city of New York to undergo
his normal role as the Angel of Death
for the criminal the criminals of the
city all while donning the war machine
armor so it's awesome because what this
does is it is it brings in a sharp
relief and it begs the question what
happens when Tony Stark decides it's
time to take the suit back that's the
question that we kind of have to ask
here but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you